here we go everyone how are you and
welcome to the first start with y book
club discussion part 1 of 6 parts during
these crazy times I hope everybody was
able to put together their own little
book club my goal with this was that we
had an opportunity a forced reason to
talk to people connect with people and
spend some time with people talking
about something other than kovat I wrote
start with why I wrote it more than 10
years ago but it came out 10 years ago
and I was thinking of doing a 10 year
anniversary edition and so I have to
reread it and I have to edit it and I
thought well if I have to reread it
wouldn't it be nice to read it with
everyone
so thank you so much for joining the
goal of today is to answer all of the
questions you have or a lot of the
questions that you have and we're live
so I'll take some live questions - the
thing that I'm loving the most right now
is just the number of people in the
number of countries I mean we've got
Tehran we've got India we've got the
Philippines we've got Scotland we've got
all over the United States we've got
hungry we've got Paris it's just
unbelievable and I'm fully aware that
some of you are up very early in the
morning but for this so thank you very
much I've got my notes here I'll tell
you a little bit about I'll still here
I'll tell you a couple little stories
first so when I first wrote start with
why I didn't realize when I first
started writing that I was writing a
leadership book I thought I was writing
a communications book and it was only as
I really started to do the research and
get into it did I realize that it's
great leaders who communicated in this
way wasn't just great marketers and it
really struck me just how much of the
world around us people who attempt to
influence our behavior with manipulation
and as many of you know that is the
primary subject of the first part of
start with Y so we're going to be doing
questions about part one okay we have
some questions that people had sent in
already but feel free to give me some of
live questions happy to take them okay
Sarah what's my first question Warren
from Worcester England yes maybe it's
easier for me to read it okay Warren
from Worcester England said within the
introduction you talk about leadership
specifically there are leaders and there
are those who lead in the current
climate of social distancing what advice
or texts and techniques can you
recommend now we have to lead our teams
remotely so there is no question that
having to lead a group of people
remotely is more difficult I mean for
years I've been preaching the importance
of iBall leadership roaming around the
office calling talking to people but in
these times where we can't physically do
that we have to do the second best thing
which is to try and connect with people
with our voices I actually think is nice
and wonderful as video conferences I
think a phone call is as powerful if not
more powerful and leaders who are
leading in this these conditions
pretend you're roaming the halls in
other words pick up the phone and call
people check in on people it's really
important to check check in on people
not just about work but just to see how
they're doing it's a remarkable thing
remember leaders care about human beings
not just about the work that they're
doing so especially people who you know
may be living alone right now
we being alone and being lonely are not
the same thing they are alone we want to
help them not feel lonely and whether
it's the middle of the day or the end of
the day calling your folks and saying
hey how are you just checking in on you
and letting them talk just being in the
ear to listen to this is one of the most
powerful things that someone can do
especially in these times let's have a
question let's take one from I have
Pavel and Justyna from Warsaw Poland
asked in Chapter one you emphasize the
role of planning and use an analogy of a
Japanese car of Japanese car factories
planning well ahead of their moves is
there a country right
you think is doing this kind of planning
well with regard to the current pandemic
well I think it's interesting it you
know has any is anybody doing planning
well now planning in the middle of it is
sort of a funny it's a funny thought but
just as the the Toyota factory planned
for something to work out right before
it got to the end where the American
factory just used this mallet to put the
door in place I hate to say it but
that's kind of like what it looks like
right now in the east and the West in
Asia South Korea China they really sort
of had a plan and stuck to it and
adapted as they went
we in the West seem to be reacting a lot
more and taking a rubber mallet to
things so ironically it looks exactly
the same as I wrote about in the book
hello from Kurdistan from Erbil I love
it
this is amazing Emily and Bruce can we
be flawed and still inspire oh what a
great question we're all flawed there is
no such thing as a perfect leader
there's no such thing as a somebody who
always starts with why we're human were
susceptible to insecurity and ego and
fear and doubt and all the things
leadership is a journey like so many
others and yes of course of course you
can be flawed and still inspired in fact
every great leader that I've ever
written about or know about every single
one of them was flawed Steve Jobs was
deeply flawed Martin Luther King was
flawed the Wright brothers were flawed
they're all flawed and I think it raises
a the interesting question which is is
it you know we can still follow and be
inspired by people despite their flaws I
think the the we hope that they can take
accountability and responsibility for
their flaws but but yes we're all deeply
flawed let's take a live question let's
see what we got here
go ahead your career how did that come
about and when did you know it was time
to find a new path ah
so someone asked I fell out of love with
my career how did that happen and how
did I get on the path to get back on I
don't know how it happened I think it
happens to a lot of us and I think it's
unpredictable I think many of us fall
out of love with the work that we're
doing I actually see this more in senior
people than junior people believe it or
not where they've been doing the same
thing they've had lots of promotions
they had all the bonuses they're
probably making a good living and they
you know rinse wash repeat they know how
to do it and it's actually later in
their careers that they start asking
themselves why the heck am I doing this
like what's this all for and I think
they have a crisis a purpose Junior my
though those things are on their mind
for sure there's so much excitement
getting a job getting the first bonus
winning the first client things like
that that sometimes purpose takes a
takes a backseat in my case I'd been
doing what I was doing for many years I
had I had my own business it was a
little marketing consultancy and and I
think I was on autopilot I don't know
but I the way I fell out of love it
wasn't it was it's like I didn't want to
wake up and do it again and and it was
very embarrassing because superficially
in my life was good I own my own
business I made an OK living we had
great clients we did great work and I
didn't want to tell people that I'd
fallen out of love with my work because
I didn't want to sound like a crybaby
like because things were seemed to be
good and it wasn't until a dear friend
of mine came to me and expressed concern
for me did it give me a safe space to
express how I actually felt and so it's
the series of strange events that led me
down the path to writing this book I
never intended to be an author I never
intended to write any books let alone as
many as I've written it was an accident
so I think one of the reasons that the
message of why has resonated with so
many people is that it's deeply human
this was not an academic exercise
and you know I have no advance degrees
from any fancy universities and it
wasn't commercial it wasn't I didn't put
it out there with the hope that you know
I could build a business around it it
was really just the desire to spread a
message that I knew resonated with me
and resonated with my friends that's
where we find myself today you and ask
me another one or shall I do what for
the paper sure I'll do another question
here when you take a pen here about this
one this one this one this one here we
go
Club de lectura dolos dragonis 13 people
from all over Sweden oh my goodness I
love it I love that you named your book
club I love this I love this what is
your experience with acquisitions
how can two or more different cultures
and Y's be combined into one such a good
question you know it's so funny when
companies choose to merge they they
evaluate what they both do they look at
the market opportunities they look at
the money that they can make but rarely
do they ever evaluate the unions of
their cultures and almost always the
reason mergers or acquisitions tend to
fail or or not be worth the money that
they expected it to be is because of
these mergers of cultures you can't take
two completely different cultures and
expect the people who work here and
belong and work here and belong to get
along with each other and share all the
same values because they don't the ways
I've seen mergers work their best is
when is when there's a matching of
cultures when when when there's a shared
set of values or if one of the companies
has been so poorly led for so long that
the the culture is basically a shambles
and and then the hopefully the company
that that buys it has a strong culture
and those those people can be subsumed
into the existing culture it's pretty
much the only way but it's happened so
often and fail so often big companies
small companies it doesn't matter
culture clash and this is what we forget
we forget this all the time companies
are simply collections of people it's
not just the product it's not just the
marketed opportunity it's a group
people have to work together with
another group of people that's why we
hire carefully so if we know that we
have to hire carefully to fit culture
how can we just assume that you can
merge with another company as if you
just hire 10,000 people all at once and
expect everybody to get along it doesn't
work that way
yes go ahead there's a live question
from the why so sassy book club in LA
and the UK what companies do I like now
that start with why there is there's a
there's a list and there they tend to be
younger companies I think the concept of
purpose and why is is is a more
important subject for younger companies
I think sweet green the salad company I
think they're pretty wonderful their
founders are very purpose-driven and
made and make a lot of business
decisions with their purpose in mind
they're all about connecting people to
fresh food and supporting local farms
and it's very community driven this is
not necessarily good for business
because they source their vegetables
from individual farms and if one farm
cannot supply all of the all of the
vegetables they need then they have to
go to a second farm so in New York City
for example but the tomatoes you get
uptown may not be the same tomatoes you
get downtown they can actually maybe
different farms because of their Drive
for for that kind of quality so this
hurts their ability to to get economies
of scale but they're so devoted to it
that's what they do
I think Airbnb is pretty close driven
and they're about connecting people and
I like them a lot of those you know the
companies that we tend to have warm
feelings to wards that I think tend to
be very purpose-driven we also have some
Purpose Driven leaders now that are kind
of remarkable and goes back to the
question was can somebody be flawed and
a good leader and the answer is yes
Elon Musk you know clearly has vision
and clearly inspires people and despite
his flaws I think he's he's doing
something pretty special
here's one from DJ quarantine DJ
quarantine I hope you're actually doing
DJ stuff while in quarantine what if you
never really had a why besides making
money but you have a successful company
now how can you establish your why ah
great question first of all every single
person on the planet has a why where
it's it's innate in all of us our why is
the sum total of how we were raised
it's the it's the the lessons we learned
from our parents the experiences we had
that make us who we are so you do have a
wide DJ quarantine you've probably just
not focused on it you would you said
you've built a business driven by money
which is fine you can have financial
success but do you feel successful do
you feel like it's all been worth it
like what you can look back at your life
and when when you're on your deathbed
and say that was a life worth living the
opportunity is not to invent a why it's
to discover a why I talked about the why
discovery process because the patterns
exist exist in us we all we just have to
go looking for them so you don't
establish it you simply go panning for
gold is what you do it's a this process
of discovery should we take a live
questions hallo Mombasa Kenya Kili
Enterprises he's a good one from nadir
that here who Rock who re excuse me
how can you detect toxic people during a
job interview ooh that's a tough one
because sometimes people are really good
at faking it you know I like asking when
I go when I interview people I think
it's a good question to interview when
you're the interviewer or the
interviewee which is what surprises can
I expect I think is a good question and
and watch how they answer also my
favorite question to ask when I when I
would interview for jobs is do you love
your job I would always ask the
interviewer do you love your job and and
I'd listen to how they answer yeah yeah
yeah I like my job a lot which is
different than love it was really funny
to watch HR people who were interviewing
me squirm when I when I would ask that
if they loved their job and they loved
the culture they're supposed to be there
selling the
company to me that was I remember those
experiences but the discovery of
toxicity I mean find find out listen to
the order in which they speak that
doesn't mean the necessarily toxic but
you'll know that their priorities you
know when you hear somebody you're
interviewing with talk about how much
they care about people and they if they
take care of their people then will will
will will have great performance if you
have if you hear somebody talk about
we're a performance-driven company and
of course our people are important then
you can see the what they prioritize
numbers over people listen to the order
in which people speak human beings are
really funny we kind of speak in the
order of the things that matter to us
most so listen to the order in which
people list their priorities you can ask
the question what matters most to the to
the leaders of this company and let's
see if they say performance and growth
first if they say our people in our
culture first that'll tell you a lot
about the culture that you're
interviewing to be inside let's take
another question do one from the page
here making good headway here andrew
redfoot asks in part one of your book
you talk about the difference between
aspiration and inspiration while clearly
delineating the differences between the
two clearly there are some similarities
between aspiration and inspiration is it
possible to take as aspiration and turn
it into into instant inspiration if so
how so let's dissect that aspirational
messages it's a little bit like
motivation and inspiration I think
aspirational messages
I think tend to be external right or
future-oriented let me think that's
through aspirational when I talk about
aspiration that's a promise it's a
promise of a future self so like you
know a gym membership a gym will
advertise and say you could look like
this but I think aspirations tend to be
external yeah I'll stick with that
aspirations tend to be external where
inspiration is something deep inside
it's values-based I
I'm struggling to think of an
aspirational message that's values based
like be a good person is a weird
aspiration so I think inspiration is
what drives us it's in its it comes from
inside of us it's based on our values
and our beliefs aspirational messages or
things we want to achieve it's things we
want to get it's places we want to go I
think it's very external and so can
aspirational messages become inspiration
I mean if we sat here and talked about
it long enough I'm sure we could find a
small Venn diagram but I think they're
pretty distinct ideas and I think a lot
of people who communicate marketers
leaders very often confuse the two and
they think by offering something someone
a promise of a future state is the same
as being inspirational so for example
when I talk about a future state that's
different it's not aspirational it's
it's it's inspirational it's it's it's I
don't know how to just yeah that's the
best I can do is one is values based on
insight and the other one is external
yes thank you somebody who so he gave me
a nice answer yes Thank You Lori Bell
you said it better than me inspiration
is internally validated the aspirations
are probably more likely to be
externally validated like that thank you
very much do you have one for me Sara
Joel drap Kenyetta fear now and where
does a wife it is so Joel asked when
fear is employed facts are incidental
how would I relate that right now um
fear is a normal human emotion and the
manipulations are the use of fear to
change people's behavior for personal
gain and what we need now is leadership
that gives us facts good and bad simply
painting rosy pictures is not really
what we need human beings can deal with
good news and human beings can do deal
with bad news
we can adjust we're very very adaptable
even for harsh conditions what we
struggle most with is is uncertainty
uncertainty for us is very difficult and
this breeds way more fear and insecurity
because we don't know how to plan for
uncertainty we can plan from bad if if
there's a hurricane or a typhoon heading
towards we know what to do it's gonna be
bad so we board up the windows we we we
know what to do we know how to prepare
we go seek shelter even if we're scared
but telling us that something Bad's
gonna happen but we don't know when
that's when we start to become paranoid
but it's also when we start it breaks
down cooperation because when we have
shared hardship we can cooperate but
when when we don't know what what's
happening and so Mis it's okay if facts
change especially now it's Kove it is a
moving target some things that were true
before are no longer true and some
things that we thought weren't true are
true the facts are changing and what we
need from our leaders is to simply say
we're fairly sure we're very sure we're
not sure but here are the facts as we
have them we'll keep you updated we can
react to those and the consistency of
those facts is really important
having cooperation amongst our leaders
especially for all of us who are from
countries there's national leadership
and there's local leadership there needs
to be communication between them so then
there can be coordination but also that
we're not getting different information
because again that breeds uncertainty
that breeds paranoia craziness and we
lock down and become much more selfish
in those times somebody asked me if I
coughed I have strained my voice so my
throat is a little rough but I am very
healthy thank you for asking
here's one that was submitted from Sara
s from the UK when you were thinking
about manipulations and the different
forms that that are out there how did
you arrive at the cat occurs at the
categorization or types you discuss in
the book
were there any pre-existing thinking
that you built upon these up built upon
these or built them that I came up
them I don't think the list is
exhaustive to be honest I think the list
of manipulations there's we could
probably come up with a lot more I came
from the marketing and advertising world
and so I was familiar with many of these
and as what always happens in a creative
process as I was writing I was writing
about things that didn't fit and so new
categories were formed so I was familiar
with some of them as I said
but-but-but-but the list is by no means
exhaustive I wanted to give a broad
selection to show that they're diverse
they're plentiful they're common I think
almost every single manipulation that I
talk to in this first part we've either
been subjected to ourselves or at least
are aware of they're not unusual
remember manipulations aren't always bad
but sometimes they're overused and can
be bad when that's all that is employed
somebody asked me when is it appropriate
to use manipulation well if you have
children there's a lot there's a lot
going on there you know I'm not against
promotions and sales and things like
that but I like it when companies are
honest about it for example it's our
end-of-year sale we need to make space
for the new stuff we're dropping the
prices so so these things can move off
the shelves
we fully aware of what's happening the
company can still be an inspiring
organization with inspiring leadership
but they want to move the product off
the shelf so they can make room for new
product there's nothing wrong with that
and we're definitely tempted to buy the
stuff that's cheaper of course but when
companies only rely on price to move
things it's a race to zero for those
organizations so manipulations aren't
always nefarious yes Olivia from Raul
yes where do we know where rolls from
doesn't say okay
one and how can I introduce tart with
Maya to my kids ten six I love that how
can I introduce start with y to my kids
ten and six yes so you know how your
kids are oily is asking you why why
daddy why daddy why daddy why daddy well
you can do the same here's the
interesting thing instead of asking why
that's the question what the question
why ironically is not the question you
ask when you want to get to why you
actually ask what why is an emotional
question and it elicits emotional
answers but what is a rational question
and people can think it through so for
example I'll give an example
why were you home late shut up dad right
versus what were you doing that your
home light was out with my friends so
what question they'll answer a why
question sometimes gets an emotional
response and as any of us who have ever
been asked the question why at work it
can sometimes make us defensive like why
did you to make that decision why did
you do it that way sometimes it's a
legitimate question but we're taken
aback because we think it's it's it's a
criticism so you can ask your kids what
were you thinking that you decided to do
that or what's on your mind or tell me
what the what your big idea is we can
start asking those questions now Oh
persons why isn't fully formed probably
until their mid to late teens so the
idea of 10:00 and 6:00 there why isn't
formed but it's being formed so what I
really really love is getting in the
habit with little kids for them to
understand the reasons why they do
things for them to sit down and explain
let's say one of them has a temper
tantrum and to sit down and say tell me
what happened that that you got so upset
as opposed to why are you screaming
right what's what's going on in your
mind that you're getting so upset and to
get the kid to open up to say well I'm
frustrated well what's frustrating well
you know my sister took that away well
tell me what tell me what's bad about
that and you go through that
conversation what an amazing skill set
they get to learn for when they grow up
I love that question let's see what else
we have in here somebody wrote Juliana B
asked would you consider to write a
children's book well I'm currently
I'm currently editing start with why for
what I'm calling it as start with why
for people still in the school it'll be
a combination of find your why and start
with why so I'm working on that right
now but in terms of a younger children
series I wrote together is better for
adults even though it looks like a
children's book but I've heard many
stories of people who actually read it
with their kids to teach them about
teamwork which really means a lot to me
what I'd love to do a children's book I
fantasize about doing a children's book
for a while so probably one day in the
future yes Lorenzo Laboon yes the essay
sww book club what what examples am I
gonna use for manipulation inspiration
in part one in the newly revised edition
you know it's funny you say that because
as I was reading it myself I read it a
couple days ago I was some of the
examples are definitely outdated you
know I talked about going to the store
to buy a camera we all used to buy
cameras and have sort of poor quality
cameras on our phones back in those days
now nobody really buys a camera unless
you're into photography so I think I
need to make adjustments like that that
are about how we actually live our lives
but I was struck by even how some of the
examples were a little bit outdated they
still resonated in other words we could
still understand it it's kind of like
reading history even though the facts
have changed and we lay you know the
examples are different what I'm going
through is not to completely change them
all I'm going to go to the ones that to
make them more relatable but even if
it's a historical example as long as the
lesson is clear I'll probably leave it
so if in fact I'm open to suggestions so
if anybody wants to write in
if you have suggestions about examples
that I could use or if you found things
completely irrelevant please don't just
call in or write in and say that was a
relevant change it
I'd like some suggestions of solutions
I'm open to everything so that is
exactly what I am going through right
now let's oh we have here
career IQ book club hello career IQ book
club
looks like you're from the Caribbean
Aruba is a small island in the Caribbean
I've been to Aruba and our economy is
88% dependent on tourism within the
current kovat crisis in less than a week
this industry is completely shut down
due to the fact that we opted to close
our borders as a way to fight ko vat19
crisis this means that our primary
source of income is completely gone how
can we use our Y as a destination to
overcome this challenge
so one of the things that crisis
provides is an opportunity for
reinvention in my newest book in in
infinite game I wrote about this concept
called existential flexibility by the
way I'm going through something very
similar you know my primary source of
income was public events well those
don't exist both other people's and my
own we had the mindset to are going
everything we we shot everything down
there and so one of the things that I've
been watching is who's doubling down on
an old business model and who's saying
okay this is an amazing opportunity to
bring our Y to life so the Y of Aruba is
not just pretty beaches and nice weather
there's plenty of other places that than
that there's there's more to it it's the
culture of the people it's who you are
it's it's where you come from and the
question is is how can you bring that to
life in other ways I think it's an
amazing opportunity so there's a few
ways to go through reinvention number
one just as an aside I'm I attended a
meeting for an arts organization this
week and there was a consultant there
too talking to us about fundraising and
it was amazing because she basically
gave the exact same presentation that
she wouldn't give she would have given
three months ago
and it was just so irrelevant I mean we
couldn't even think about it and so the
opportunity is what would a rubra do if
there was no such thing as tourism like
start from scratch if there was no such
thing as tourism and people never
traveled ever again
what kind what how would a rubra sell
itself and I and I highly recommend
asking people who are on the front lines
of tourism it's not the people who are
in government it's not the people who
run companies who are gonna solve this
problem you want to ask people from the
front lines people who are in it
everyday they have lots of great ideas
so one of the things that we did in our
company and I got this idea from my
friend Jen Waldman which is take a group
of people people who have a go-get-'em
attitude who believe some good can come
of this and ask them to come up with 15
ideas each in 48 hours of what Aruba
could become of what kind of economy
Aruba could build if there's no such
thing as tourism 15 ideas each and then
when you get together as a group you
explain this is about contribution not
competition it doesn't matter if we like
six per one of six about one person's
ideas and none of another person's ideas
it doesn't matter we're all putting this
together to help each other that's the
idea it's about contribution not a
competition and I told the story to my
team we did this as a team everybody on
my team had to give 15 new ideas in 48
hours
and I told the team about a story that I
that I learned from the Marine Corps I
visited OCS Officer Candidate School
which is where the Marine Corps selects
its officers and they were telling me
that when they evaluate a future officer
a future leader in the Marine Corps
they're looking at their leadership
skills in other words their ability to
ask for advice take counsel and then
make a decision and be decisive but
they're also looking for followership
skills which is they're looking for
people to contribute ideas and if the
leader selects an idea or a course of
action that is different than the one
that you think is the right one it
doesn't matter you put your idea aside
and you work tirelessly to see that the
leaders decision is successful and if it
fails you don't sit back and say well I
told you so you work tirelessly to work
to achieve success so this is the story
I told that we're
in this together and I only asked for
two or three ideas from each person at a
time because I didn't want one person to
go through a whole list because I knew a
lot of people had the same ideas and the
reason I asked for 15 it sounds like a
lot is because I knew that if I asked
for three from each people from each
person that aisle there would be so much
overlap I'd get very few ideas the
really really good ideas happen lower
down on the list when people were really
thinking hard because there was a ton of
overlap and on the on the easy stuff the
easy stuff I could have come up with
I wanted my the the everybody's really
great thinking so I would go to the
people of Aruba put together a group put
together multiple groups and ask them to
come up with 15 ideas in 48 hours each
of what Aruba could be like if there was
no such thing as tourism and see what
happens I think you'll be surprised
oh there's here's one I've gone from ma
cheeky this is the cheeky cheeky breeky
book club in Prague I love it Prague is
a wonderful city my grandparents were
from Prague
my last name is Czech okay why should I
know my why when I'm either an
entrepreneur nor a manager but a regular
person or employee who just wants to
improve I'm gonna sneeze I can feel it
it might happen in the middle okay I'll
take a little drink first of all you
don't have to learn your wife you don't
want to learn it the first criterion of
being a leader is my friend General
George Flynn explains to me the first
criterion to be a leader is you have to
want to be one I never try and twist
anybody's arm to learn there why even if
I know in the core of my being that
it'll help them whether it's to find joy
in their life join their relationships
joy in their work my rule is if you you
have to ask me if you want to find your
way so I'll of course help my friends
but and I tell my friends the answer is
gonna be yes but I'm you have to you
have to ask and so to the cheeki breeki
book club if you don't wanna know it you
don't want to know it that's right but
what I do know is is that knowing your
why is and having that sense of
foundation it builds confidence I mean
Iram I can think back that when I
learned my why
the first thing that happened to me was
this overwhelming sense of calm a calm
confident confidence came over me I'm
much more certain about decisions I make
personally and professionally because at
the end of the day it doesn't matter if
you're an entrepreneur or you're or a
manager you're a human being and this is
a human this is a human experience so I
hope you do want to learn you're why one
day because I can tell you that it's a
magical experience and it puts you on an
entirely new path for the rest of your
life yes from the evil book club in
Georgia yes
manipulating why our company's still
manipulating even though we're aware
that we're being manipulated because it
works because it works and I think that
one of the biggest ways to avoid being
manipulated is simply to be aware of the
manipulations and we can still choose to
do it I mean look I still buy I'm still
tempted to buy things because of all the
manipulations you know one that I would
add to the list that has that's not in
the book is scarcity you know only three
left you know that that one how many
times have we all gone online to buy
something like buy it now there's only
four left we all panic you know gotta
get it got to get it even though we
don't need it
scarcity is a way of manipulating people
you know I'm I'm I fall for it every
time
not every time but I still for it fall
for it a lot because it works that's why
companies do it but I think the more
we're aware of it and when we go
shopping or when we are voting or when
we're making decisions or when others
are trying to get behavior out of us
like our bosses to be aware of it means
that we can still do those things but we
we can go into it with eyes wide open I
think it's really manipulative
manipulative when we go into it with
eyes shut
Lennon Reyes can I find my Y at forty
three you can find your Y at any age you
like I've done Y discoveries with people
in their 60s and 70s there's no right
time or wrong time to find your why the
time to find your Y is when you want to
find it so if you're 43 years old and
you want to find your why
you know absolutely absolutely
you have more information to call upon
to help help you find it it's actually a
little a little easier so the question
was from Aspen 1955
hello Aspen 1955 I hope you're in Aspen
beautiful part of the world if you are
if you're not you should go there
sometime has my why change well here's
the great thing about a Y it never
changes I've tweaked the words a tiny
bit over the years but fundamentally my
Y is exactly the same as it's always
been my entire life we are who we are
are Y a little of the experiences we had
growing up as I said right at the
beginning and so you can't change who
you are you can make decisions to be
more in line with who you are but you
are who you are and when you're out of
balance when you're not following your
why people can tell our friends say DOS
it's like I don't know you anymore I
it's like it's like I don't know who you
are that's because we're making
decisions that are inconsistent with our
Y so the reason to learn our one of the
reasons to learn our Y is that we can
start making decisions that are more
consistent with our Y and the more to
sit the more consistent we are with our
Y then people will know who we are
people will say you are authentic you
are have integrity you are honest people
can start they can make predictions
about how you'll react because you're
relatively consistent so my Y has never
changed just like yours has never
changed the opportunity is to discover
what it is oh and that's a good question
and my Y is to inspire people to do the
things that inspire them so that each of
us can change our world for the better
and that's my standard my standard for
the books I write the things that I do
even this my goal is to inspire so I
hope that you're feeling inspired as we
do this that is the ultimate compliment
you can ever pay me because it goes
right to my why it's it speaks right to
me do you have a question yes
laurens black row black rose fly low
florence black rose great name how
should an artist apply there why - to
gain audience is that with the question
so artists communicate not in words but
in whatever their chosen form is they
may communicate in dance or song or or
in a painting but it's you know an
artist that taps into their why the
opportunities how to bring that to life
so one thing artists can do is learn a I
would really need to learn to do is
actually learn the words for their why
because what it does is it helps provide
the context for the work that they do
so even work that fails if you
understand where it's born out of you
can still respect it so for example I'm
a huge fan of modern dance love it
I go to BAM the Brooklyn Academy of
Music as often as I can to go see dance
I've also walked out of more things from
BAM than anywhere else before and yet I
love the organization because I know
they're why they're why is a large part
about about challenging me challenging
their audiences and sometimes they show
me things that challenge me and they've
also they're also challenging the the
choreographers to push push their
boundaries I know that going in so even
when I see something that I hate and I
walk out of I'm still grateful to BAM
how amazing is that that's something I
walked out of and I'm still grateful so
the the value of of knowing your why and
being able to communicate it to others
provides the context from where the work
comes from and then you attract more
people who believe that so if you are an
artist please please please learn to put
your why into words and thank you for
all the lovely compliments how inspired
you are thank you sir Isaac office ooh
that's very nice of you Jill polgár so
nice of you to say so thank you very
very much so kind you're warming what
you're warming my heart and risk I love
them too
yeah around pivoting using your mind
pivot during for company that leaders
during time of crisis yeah okay
so how to use your why to pivot in time
of crisis okay so let me give you a
tangible example so it makes more sense
so what I do is public speaking it's one
of the things I do but it's one of what
I do what I do is public speaking right
so if I were to pivot based on what it
limits my creativity right so I'm
pivoting based on what really my only
options are to give speeches online so
the only opportunity I have is to put on
a conference online and charge money for
tickets for people to come to my
conference on line doesn't that seems
very limited and it doesn't seem
repeatable I mean how many of those
could I even do so so you don't want to
pivot on what because it limits
creativity so I'm pivoting on why so my
wise to inspire people to do the things
that inspire them so we're asking
ourselves not how do we do more public
speeches online we're asking ourselves
what ways can we take advantage of in
this modern world to inspire people to
do the things that inspire them and what
we're doing is we're going through
everything we've done and we realize we
have tons of content that we never
realized had any value to the outside
world for example we found a way to do
362 reviews for our own company we
invented it for ourselves and we do it
for ourselves well we we can share that
with other people
we found a way to do evaluations we call
it perform we call it growth and
performance GNP I'm it's super simple
one sheet way to evaluate it well we can
share that with people we're realizing
that our work the importance of being
inspired not giving a speech the
importance of being inspired is more
valuable now than ever we're doing a
book club that's that was born out of
this pivot we're realizing that starting
helping people start their Huddle's
teaching people how to do Huddle's
teaching people how to do Huddle's
because we've been doing them for years
we're a virtual team is something we can
offer even showing up for five minutes
or 10 minutes at the beginning of
someone's huddle is something we can
offer so you can see I'm poor we're
pouring with ideas and by the way these
aren't all my ideas these came from the
team but the point is is
because we're pivoting based on what we
believe to inspire people to do the
things that inspire them we're finding
lots of opportunities that we can bring
to life in a digital world but if I
pivot it based on what it'd be all over
and I and I see that happening all over
the place which is companies are trying
to like go back to the question about
Aruba like how do we do tourism now you
don't you don't do tourism now the
question is where what is your why and
how do you how do you bring that to life
in a world where there is no tourism
that's gonna yield a lot of great ideas
let me take one from me new menu asks
how do you differentiate between a
leader who inspires and a leader who
depends upon their charisma it takes
time and the news cheating a little bit
because that's deeper in the book and so
I haven't read that section yet but if I
go by memory charisma is is you know
people confused deep belief in something
and high energy and sometimes leaders
with high energy are they're fun they're
fantastic they're fun to be around
we we we feel we feel inspired in the
moment but I wouldn't call it
inspiration
I'd call it excitement and motivation
because very very often after they leave
we just would go back the way things
were
inspiration lasts longer I think of
inspiration a little bit like love right
like you don't like your kids every day
but you love your kids every day
motivation and excitement and energy
those things can be fun and exciting and
wonderful we want to be around those
people but when times are tough and when
the energy is down are we still inspired
to follow them and and help build the
vision so I think the the difference
between inspiration and and charisma is
revealed in time hold on that was one
that there's a Jean Tuttle here I had
the pleasure of seeing you at Travis Air
Force Base a great base many years ago
yeah it's been many years since I was at
Travis as continue as a continued member
of the Air Force
a medicine mmm AFA medicine your message
still Renee resonates amongst the team
thank you so much that's so nice of you
to say I have a very warm spot for the
Air Force in my heart the Air Force was
one of the first organizations to
discover my work they discovered the
concept of why months after I first
articulated it and were big time early
adopters so I've had a long relationship
with the Air Force and now with the with
the other branches as well so big love
the question was when are you doing the
next book club we put up a schedule the
next one will be on the 11th which is
next Saturday they're all every Friday
at the exact same time except next week
because of the holidays we're doing it
on Saturday
so next weeks on the 11th on Saturday
please join if you can and we will be
doing part two of the book and then all
the subsequent parts following and you
know if this goes well maybe we'll do
book clubs for the other books I haven't
decided should we do some more sure
let's do some more
Lupe Hernandez yes what do you do when
you're giving up on your why who I
that's a hard one if you're giving up on
your why I would there's two things I
would recommend one is was it really
your why like did you actually get it
right because Y is so core to who you
are and it helps you get out of bed in
the morning that you may not have the
energy to do it every day that I've
definitely had that I definitely not
wanted to do it but I never gave up on
it I've definitely had days where I was
exhausted and was fed up but I still I
still believed in it so if you're giving
up on your why I the first question I'd
ask is whatever you articulated was that
actually or why this and the second
thing I would raise is please call a
friend which is the if we're if no
matter especially in these kovat times I
think two things we all have to be we
have to get really really good at which
I think we've all got a little lazy
because
on Facebook and Instagram and we feel
like we're connected with our friends
because we see what they're doing but we
don't actually call them and say hi you
know we feel connected with our friends
when we watch them on social media but
we don't actually connect with our
friends because they're on social media
so I think we all got a little lazy I
think one thing we all have to get
better at is calling our friends and
saying how are you are you okay and
sometimes mustering up the courage to
call somebody and say I'm not okay I'm
having a behind day today can we just
talk and sometimes sometimes it's just
nice to say that loud or sometimes
people just want to listen we just want
to be heard like we don't have to have
fix everything all the time I talked to
a friend this morning who's really
really struggling she's alone during
kovat and she she's in pain but she has
back problems and so she gave us out of
bed in pain and she can't go see her
doctor and and I can't fix anything
there's nothing I can physically do to
alleviate her or her state but I can
just be there and listen and we got on
FaceTime and we just talked and she
cried a little bit and we just talked
and it was just it's nice
so please call people and please call
them and and and take their call and
they call you I think we have five more
minutes we'll do a couple more questions
and then we'll wrap it up Gabby from
Baltimore yes Steve started with why
inspiring people around him it's unclear
to me how Apple inspires people so the
question that Gaby asked is you can see
how Martin Luther King inspired people
but it is unclear how Apple inspired
people so the question is I think
there's two questions in there I can
explain how Apple did it the other
question is is does Apple still do it
that's a question for another day you
know if you look at the fierce loyalty
that Apple used to command in all its
products it was kind of amazing and it
did for decades and I think one of the
signs that Apple inspired is that people
would stick Apple stickers on
they're pcs from work because they
didn't want anybody to think that they
were a PC person they wanted everybody
to know that they were an Apple person
it was a state of mind it was a way of
viewing the world it's the way we viewed
ourselves Apple people view themselves
as rebels as creatives it's why Apple
was so attractive to artists and young
people because artists and young people
tend to view themselves as rebels are
creative and when Steve Jobs died
there's this weird sort of Princess
Diana like outpouring of love people
were leaving wreaths outside Apple
stores I mean think about that for
except for a second people were leaving
wreaths for a billionaire outside his
retail establishments he is crazy
but the reality is is that the way that
Apple communicated and the way the
company was built in a culture of the
company was really about challenging
status quo and it's and it was born in
their culture it wasn't just marketing
marketing was the manner in which they
communicated out loud so I had the
opportunity to visit Apple headquarters
just recently and there had a walk down
the campus with a head historian and he
was explaining to me that you know they
hire people some from some of these big
companies you know the Facebook's and
the googles of the world and these
people come in with their big salaries
and their big egos and they tell you
what they've done in the past and look
at my resume and they're all fancy and
Apple said to them we don't care what
you've done in the past the thing we're
curious about was what are you gonna do
in the future and is that there's still
that that pushed the boundaries
rebellious spirit the question is do
they still do it is it as strong as it
used to be that's a different
conversation I think we'll do one last
question and we'll call it a day
let's see do you have one yeah yeah
Thomas from Srilanka
level manager convey the idea why to the
top management when the organization is
lacking ah how can a middle level
manager convey the why to top level
management when the organization is
lacking the why okay lots going on there
so the question so it does happen where
senior management has lost sight of the
why that is true
Microsoft under Steve Ballmer senior
management had lost sight of the why but
middle management still knew what it was
especially those who'd been there for a
long time and so the opportunity is
still to is I talked about this in
leaders elast the opportunities to be
the leader you wish you had the
opportunity is for you to start with
walleye for you to ins by your team you
to remind your team what makes this
company great and where the company
comes from in other words what is the
origin of the company and why you fell
in love with this company talking about
personal connection say I love this
company because when I first came here
and talking about your personal
connection and your connection to why is
really the way you do it and and that
creates these wonderful little teams
that are starting with why and overtime
you hope the tail can wag the dog which
it generally does because what happens
in these these higher performing teams
is they management senior management
either leaves them alone because they're
doing well or they want to know what
you're up to because you're doing well
and sometimes some of those people are
promoted out and moved to other teams
and they take what they've learned and
before you know it it starts to spread
and the tail wag the dog this is exactly
what happened at Microsoft it was kept
alive by enough people and when Steve
Ballmer left the the founding why came
bursting back to life immediately thanks
to all the middle managers who are
keeping the flame lit and that is I
think a perfect way to wrap up
oh I'm apparently we're having a Wi-Fi
issue sorry the video is choppy we will
fix that before Saturday so if you've
had choppy video I apologize this is an
infinite game and we're learning every
constant improvement constant
improvement so we'll fix that by
Saturday
any other notes that I need to say
reminder we're gonna do part two of
start with y on Saturday April 11th so
bring your questions make sure you get
together with your book club before then
to discuss it first because remember the
whole point of this is that we have our
book clubs it'll be at the same time 3
p.m. Eastern time in the United States
if you want to watch any part of this R
you watch it or if you missed it a
friend missed it all of these book clubs
will be available on youtube forever and
we'll put them in all the other social
media platforms if you want to revisit
any part next week we're going to talk
about an alternative perspective and
this is where we start really getting
into the introduction of why in the
Golden Circle
I'm looking forward to reading that
chapter it's been a lot of years
remember to send your questions to book
club at simon Sinek calm that's book
club at simon Sinek calm and of course
we'll also be taking live questions as
well thank you for joining me everyone
this has been fun and inspiring so
lovely to see you all from around the
world you know what's so amazing is that
i'm reading all of these cities and
countries around the world and it's a
strange feeling that we're all actually
going through the same experience at the
same time it actually makes me feel very
close to everyone so thank you very very
much for being here I hope to see you
all again next week take care of
yourselves take care of others we'll see
you soon
you